>>> We're back with our politics
lead.
A trump aligned super pac is
demanding a Florida ethics
investigation into whether
Florida governor Ron Desantis'
political activities is
violating state law, accusing
him of running shadow
presidential campaign, saying
Ron Desantis should have to
resign from office.
Let's discuss.
Gloria, what do you make of
this?
>> Well, an ethics complaint
filed by friends of Donald Trump
is something I have a hard time
getting my arms around, but it's
a nuisance lawsuit.
Have you ever met a politician
who was holding one elected
office while seeking another?
I've never met one.
Every one of them is.
So this is just -- gives us an
indication that Donald Trump and
his friends are willing to throw
everything they possibly can at
any time, at any moment against
Ron Desantis.
>> There's much more to come.
We saw a poll yesterday, a CNN
poll, with Republican voters.
Trump at 40%, Desantis at 36%.
That's basically a tie.
>> It shows just how much
Desantis is on his mind.
We're already starting to see
some factions sort of
development in this early
contest for the Republican
nomination.
You can already see pence and
Nikki Haley on one side, as well
as Desantis and trump trying to
compete for a similar base, as
well.
You can point to the recent
comments about Ukraine that
Desantis made as well, which
aligns with trump's stance
before hand.
So we're seeing these two take
jabs at each other.
And what's hanging over it is
the fact that they seem to be
trying to outtrump one another
and compete for the base.
>> There's a new poll out from
quinnipiac in favor of Desantis,
it's with independent voters.
In a head-to-head matchup, 49%
of independents favor Desantis
over Biden, Biden 45%.
But then you have a biden/trump
matchup, and 50% of independents
go to Biden, versus 42% for
trump.
Obviously, it's way early, and
Desantis hasn't even announced a
candidacy.
As you know, Republicans lost
independents by a wide margin in
2018.
In 2020, they split evenly with
them.
This is a strong argument for
Ron Desantis.
>> I don't know if you're going
to win independents by waging
war on business, waging culture
wars.
There's still a lot of tires to
be kicked when it comes to Ron
Desantis for voters in Iowa and
New Hampshire.
I don't think that the
independents will be -- I don't
think independents will go for
Ron Desantis once he gets
through a primary.
I think at this point in 1995,
Bill Clinton was worried about
Lamar Alexander.
>> I think you may be able to
win independents by going to war
with Wall Street.
I think that poll number you
just showed, look, I know
Republicans don't trust polls.
I'm a Republican pollster, I
hear it all the time.
But numbers like that are the
best thing Ron Desantis has
going for him.
Because for years, I said the
number one thing I hear from
Republican voters is they want
someone who fights, they want
someone who fights.
After these midterms, they want
someone who wins.
The fight is not enough.
You have to fight and win.
And if there is a perception out
there that grows that Donald
Trump is just not the guy to win
any more.
He's good at throwing punches
but not good at landing them as
much, and Ron Desantis is the
winner, that helps him eat into
that trump base.
Not all the way, but that's the
strongest thing going.
>> What was interesting in our
poll yesterday is that it showed
Republicans really care more
about a candidate who shares
their values rather than a
candidate who can win, which was
stunning to me.
But these are trump supporters,
obviously.
Right?
And so that's kind of a shift
that we have seen over the last
what, four to six years maybe?
>> What do you make of the fact
that Desantis has -- his
position on Ukraine doesn't
sound the same as his position
in 2014?
Obviously, different
circumstances, et cetera.
He came out and said skrain not
-- Ukraine is not a vital
interest to the United States.
Here are some of the more
establishment Republicans
disagreeing with Ron Desantis.
>> I have a different point of
view.
I believe it's very much in the
interest of America to honor our
word.
>> I can't imagine what XI
jinping or the leadership in
Iran would think if we took that
course of action.
>> To say this doesn't matter is
to say that war crimes don't
matter.
>> I don't know what he's trying
to do or the goal.
Obviously, he doesn't deal with
foreign policy every day.
>> I think this is a much bigger
issue than a territorial
dispute.
>> But my question is, does that
help Desantis with the base?
>> I mean, this is the
interesting question here.
I mean, you have two of some of
the more prominent members of
the Republican
similarly spoken views,
separating themselves from
potentially the rest of the
pack.
But I wonder too, just that
wording of territorial dispute.
This reflects the concern of
many Republicans on the hill, as
well as many foreign policy
experts.
Say you do at one point have
higher office, even if you get
to a point of needing to
advocate for it, even if you
don't agree with this.
To say territorial dispute now
really belittles this war at
this point.
If you're in a position in the
future where you are trying to
advocate for foreign aid, and
U.S. Support of this war, and
somebody who is opposed to it
might bring up the fact that
hey, you once called this a
territorial dispute.
>> Trump was able to drive his
party away from free trade in
2016.
He's very persuadable with his
base of support.
And he's been waging this sort
of like quest to isolate the
country from foreign
entanglements.
I think it's a very dangerous
policy for Republicans.
>> It's definitely risky for
Desantis to take this position.
If I look at the types of
Republican voters who lean more
towards Desantis than Donald
Trump, they're split on this
issue.
I've been asking this question
for over a year, do you think
this is in the U.S.' vital
national interest to support
Ukraine?
They're pretty split with
Desantis voters.
Does he push them into saying
Nikki Haley or Mike pence's
arms?
On the other hand, the trend
line has moved.
It used to be only a third of
Republicans said I don't think
that's in our interest.
That's risen to almost half.
So if Ron Desantis is headed
where he thinks that trend line
will continue going, where he
thinks a year from now we may be
asking this question again, he
may be trying to "Skate where
the puck is going."
>> I think this is becoming the
fault line in the Republican
party.
It's easy for somebody like
speaker Mccarthy to say no blank
check for Ukraine.
What does that mean?
As the primaries play out, the
candidates are going to have to
get more specific about what
they think and believe.
What is the territorial dispute?
What is our responsibility when
it comes to Ukraine?
Is democracy at stake in the
world or not?
I mean, I think these are
questions that have to be asked.
>> There's also going to be a
burden on the white house to
keep making the case for
democracy, and why we're there,
and why this, a, should not be
in dispute.
And Kevin Mccarthy, I'm sure,
was happy.
>> So two of the first
Republican congressman to
endorse Donald Trump, have now
endorsed Ron Desantis.
And today, congressman chip Roy
formally endorsed Desantis.
Again, Desantis has not
announced he's running.
But congressman Roy wrote the
next president must be a vie
brant and energetic leader with
the vision to chart a new
course.
That leader is Ron Desantis.
I have to believe that is wish
casting.
He wants Desantis to run.
>> Desantis hasn't announced
yet.
It also didn't stop a former
trump deputy secretary of
homeland security supporting Ron
Desantis in Ken cucinelli.
>> I didn't even know that.
>> Look, right now, you see that
there are many members of the
Republican party that still
don't want to lose.
So many people that supported